happy Sunday believe nation Nina's off
to her acupuncture appointment and so
I've got some ninja projects to work on
while she's gone what stay tuned
[Music]
it's been a crazy week for us I've been
sick all week Nina's been working like
crazy and so I thought while she's out
instead of working like I normally do
I'm going to give her a couple of
surprises prize number one this kind
that was a mess there's stuff everywhere
and so when Nina comes home I wonder
coming home to a clean place it's time
to get to work
BAM look at that clean condo
next up Nina does not like this beard I
know I know you guys love it
Nina does not so it's coming off
surprise number two BAM look at that
whew I'm like 10 pounds lighter yeah
I've got a couple minutes a little bit
of time before he comes back I'm gonna
go to a store and see if I can find her
surprise number three surprise two and a
half take the garbage out I don't do
that enough I'm sorry Nina and I'm doing
it today goodbye surprise number three
Nina's not really into that much stuff
so I got her a thank you for being
awesome card I'm gonna write a nice
thoughtful message inside
next up she wanted to go shopping for
kale so I'm gonna do it for her alright
surprise number four done for huge
bunches of kale they also got her a
special salad full of her favorite
healthy ingredients that she can have
something to eat when she comes home
then we got a rush back and set up
before she gets here is what I come home
to you guys sleeping in the Sun when
Nina comes home you better have more
excitement and energy excitement and
energy excitement and energy guys for
Nina there we go
I had a little extra time so bonus
number five dress the dogs up
we got minion Teemo and cow girl just
Anna
I hate Justin the dogs up but Nina loves
it so she'll be surprised yeah she's
here she's here she's here hello Nina oh
oh that the husband shaved oh look at
that oh look how clean this condo
oh wow surprise that's some energy team
oh good job doggies good job open the
fridge oh holy cow there's some kale oh
my god what's that what's that card and
special salad oh wow that is some that
is some crazy town right there Wow
if you dig deep there's lots of special
veggies all your favorites in there
that's because I thought you might be
hungry coming home from the acupuncture
oh and a card Wow look at that that's
pretty crazy too I licked that that's my
own saliva on that envelope
[Music]
we love you Nina
we love you are so special okay I'm
gonna stop filming so I can get my wife
a hug now we love you